in this video we'll talk about the
concepts of core promoter elements
so core promoters are generally defined
as a stretch of DNA that directs the
initiation of transcription
so the general transcription Factor
binds to these core promoter elements
and initiate the recruitment of RNA Paul
2 thereby transcription starts
so transcription at the core promoter is
mediated by the basal transcription
Machinery or the pre-initiation complex
now there could be different types of
promoter and core promoter elements
the promoter is comprising of several
core promoter elements there could be
Upstream core promoter elements such as
the so-called data box or bre Elements
which is situated Upstream to the
transcription start site
there could be also Downstream promoter
element which is located Downstream to
the so-called transcription start site
question is how long is a core promoter
element core promoter element can be
roughly 100 base pair to thousand base
pair long depend on a specific Gene and
a specific promoter element
okay these are examples of some generic
core promoter element
such as bre data INR element dce DC 2 DP
all these kind of elements so don't
think all these elements exist in a
promoter
these are majority of the possibilities
that a core promoter can be
so in a real life scenario there would
be particular combinations of these
which would exist in a promoter element
and there are specific proteins that can
bind to these kind of promoted elements
such as tf2b bind specifically to the
Brie element tf2d binds to the data box
element
Etc
now there are no Universal core promoter
element that are present in all the
promoters so there would be
some combination of promoter elements
present in one gene
a completely different combination can
be present in another Gene
there are different types of core
promoter elements
important for different kind of
transcription Factor binding
now let us understand this with an
example so in one case let us say data
box or bre are together present in a
promoter element
that can be one situation there could be
other situation where dce or DP are
together
so that is another situation but you
won't find Tata box Brie dce DP all
together in one gene promoter that's not
possible
now there are two different classes of
promoters known as focused promoters and
dispersed promoters
Focus promoters are those promoters
where the transcription start site are
very unique and at one particular point
and these kind of promoters are seen for
regulated genes
and dispersed promoter has
transcriptional start site at many
locations
and these are valuable for any kind of
like housekeeping genes
now let's talk about the canonical core
promoter elements we have already
discussed what are some examples of
canonical core promoter elements but
besides them there are non-canonical
core promoter Elements which doesn't
have any of these known well-known well
characterized promoter elements it just
has a broad region designated as core
promoter element and these are known as
non-canonical ones such as
cpg Islands atg dessert and also
the transcription initiation platform or
TPI tips
so these are pretty much non-canonical
and they are discovered recently
previously people even didn't appreciate
that they are there are these kind of
promoter elements so it turns out if we
think about Tata box that is present in
only a very selected set of transcripts
but Tata box is most characterized
that's why we see it in the books
so let's talk about the transcription
initiation the role of core promoter
element in this particular process so
Tata box core promoter is really
important for the TF2 D2 bind tf2d has
the Tata box binding protein as a
subunit which binds to the particular
DNA and tough or terabox spining protein
Associated Factor
is a transcription activation domain so
it interacts with other molecules
so
in this example the tf2d can actually
distort the DNA architecture it can
create a 90 degree almost 90 degree Bend
and it interacts with the DNA with the
help of beta pleated sheet which is
non-typical to any transcription Factor
generally transcription Factor interacts
with each other with the DNA
via Alpha helix
all these kind of nitty-gritty details
about
uh the transcription Factor binding and
general transcription Factor binding to
the core promoter element came from
extra crystallographic studies
later on tf2b binds to the DNA just
adjacent to the Tata box which is the
Brie element so Brie element at data box
often coexist together in a core
promoter eventually other components
like tf2f tf2 etf2h would bind tf2h
would phosphorylate the tail of the RNA
polymerase which is a start signal for
the RNA polymerase to move along the
Gene and thereby transcription starts
now let me tell you there are strong
promoters there are weak promoters
how do you know what are strong
promoters and weak promoters so the
readout is very simple the amount of RNA
that are produced strong promoter would
produce more and more rounds of
transcription so more MRNA would be
produced one can use reporter Gene
assays
where they place a reporter Gene such as
a gfp coding sequence underneath a
particular promoter to understand and
ask the question whether it's a strong
promoter or a weak promoter so in this
example you can see
hypothetically two molecules of gfp are
produced
and in the next example you can see four
molecules of jfp are produced so
obviously
the Promoter on the right hand side
is a stronger promoter than the left
hand side and this can be figured out
using reporter genasic the fluorescence
intensity will indirectly show us how
strong a promoter is in this case
okay now when we talk about the promoter
elements we have to think about the
histone signatures in the promoter
element
because all these histone signatures
would determine many aspects most of the
cases core promoter elements are
nucleosome free regions
there are other situations as well
mostly there are specific histone
modifications are associated with
promoter associated nucleosomes
one of the modification is H3 k27
trimethylation and another modification
is h3k for tried methylation h3k4
trimethylation opens up the DNA near the
promoted region whereas h3k27
trimethylation makes it more condensed
so the type of Eastern modification that
is associated with the promoted region
DNA would determine the fate of
transcription
anyway there are techniques like chip
sequencing which can tell us about what
type of histone variants are present in
the core promoter element chip
sequencing against h2a Z variant of
histone histone uh molecule found out
that this particular histone is highly
enriched in the transcription start site
whereas the H 3.3 is pretty much all
over the place in the along the gene
body as well as in the promoter so these
kind of small modifications and small
signatures are really important to
understand how promoter elements are
bringing out the transcription
I hope this was useful if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe you
can support us via super thanks see you
in next video